[Musique]
alors une fois que le dioxyde de carbone
est captée on va le dissoudre bandeau
est ici on est sur le site d'injection
donc le dioxyde de carbone qui décide
dans l'eau il va arriver par ce trio là
jusqu'à entrer dans le puits où il va
être injecté dans la roche volcanique à
une profondeur entre 800 et 2 km de
profondeur
[Musique]
e
le dioxyde de carbone on va injecter
dans le sous-sol dans la gt dans ce type
de roche une roche basaltique comme vous
pouvez voir si les roches très très
poreuse qui agit vraiment comme une
éponge vous voyez tous les petits points
blancs ce sont des minérales de calcite
donc ces deux-là dioxyde de carbone qui
a été transformé en ruche
[Musique]